this is a Louisiana pine snake if we  didn't show it to you you'd probably  never see it or it's distinct yellow and  Brown splotch scales it's one of the  rarest snakes in North America the  Louisiana pine snake can grow up to six  feet long it's not poisonous it's a  constrictor it wraps its prey and  suffocates them it's 9:00 habitat is  estimated to be less than 200 square  miles in the longleaf pine forests on  the Louisiana Texas border a habitat  that is only 3% of its once massive size  it's almost impossible to spot in the  wild because the snake spends its time  below ground moving through the tunnels  of its rodent prey but when it perks its  head above ground its habitat is in  steady decline fewer trees mean fewer  rodents barring beneath and that means  fewer pine snakes and with encouraging  human development the ever-present  threat of being crushed under road  traffic looms this is Louisiana pine  snake  you  [Music]